[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[BELL RINGING]
Welcome to Section 5 where we'll
discuss advanced topics that
will assist you in integrating
RedisSearch and RedisJSON
into your application.
The commands and topics
covered in this section
may not be necessary
for every application.
However, it is important to
know that such actions do exist
should certain scenarios arise.
RedisSearch and
RedisJSON are constantly
evolving with new
features and capabilities.
So this section will expand as
newer versions are released.
As always, we
encourage you to jump
into the discussion on
Discord as we are always
interested in what our students
would like to see covered.
This will be a light
section with one
collective hands-on
activity at the end.
Well then proceed
to the final exam
where you can earn a
certificate of completion
if you reach a grade
of 65% or higher.
Good luck and happy learning.